well with the passage of time the
rhetoric on illegal immigration on the
left has become increasingly brazen and
the attentions of those who espouse it
are less disguised than they've ever
been so in the 1990s Bill Clinton
pledged to deport illegal immigrants he
got elected on that pledge in the 2000s
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton touted
their efforts to secure the border then
as President Obama created daca and
other programs to block deportation for
certain favored illegal immigrant groups
now in the trump presidency the mask is
off the left tells us that no illegal
immigrant should ever be deported even
ones who have committed crimes not only
that they should be allowed to vote
Cesar Vargas and Jennifer Palmieri have
both hinted about that recently on the
show watch I do believe that we should
have universal voting for everyone to
ensure that everyone has citizens of
other countries something public should
be able to vote here no taxation without
representation who comes to the United
States and buys a decker Marlboros and
pays the sales tax is entitled to vote
that's what you're saying if that person
comes here to contribute to the country
let him have a say in his government let
foreigners vote I hope the Democratic
Party runs on that I think it'd be a fun
election but the details matter so you
said that non-citizens should never vote
in elections I argue that your party
will overtake you in that question soon
but we'll see well it's bet you know
maybe if Congress never does anything to
address immigration would any other
country tolerate that with that idea be
taken seriously anyplace but in the
United States Mexico doesn't take it
seriously in fact the Mexican
Constitution explicitly says quote
foreigners shall not in any way involve
themselves in the political matters of
the country nobody's attacking Mexico
for that Mexico is not being denounced
as racist for not letting Salvadorans
vote because it's obvious only Mexicans
should dictate Mexican politics that's
why Mexico is a country only in the
United States is there a different
standard and it's because the left sees
the new standard as a way to obtain
power and hold it forever cathy roux is
founding publisher of Catalina magazine
and unlike many on the Left very honest
about what she thinks some were grateful
for that she
tonight say Kathy you think that people
who are not citizens the United States
ought to be allowed to vote in federal
elections correct I feel that people who
are contributing and are humans and are
in our society and contributing to our
society should have a say yes and what
happens in our democracy yeah would we
how would we measure that so would we
say that everyone who's making a net
contribution paying more in taxes than
they're getting in services for example
those people can vote people in property
at the moment I mean we have so many
people that are living in this country
we have about 11 and 12 million people
that are living in this country
contributing to our society paying their
taxes as that previous guest had said
taxation without representation so there
are so many people who are living here
but don't have a voice so it's been
shown that when they do have a voice and
they do feel more empowered and they are
part of our society so it definitely
would feel more empowered by voting
there's no doubt mean you're absolutely
right on that they would definitely be
empowered but I'm just wondering what
the standard is so could I be on
vacation here from another country and
you know stay for a while contribute
greatly how long would I have to stay in
order to be able to vote well I mean I
think it goes state-by-state and I think
Maryland right now has a few cities that
allows undocumented people to vote so
are you wondering how Maryland is doing
it and that's not California that's
Maryland raises a question is doing in
other states so if foreigners should be
allowed to vote in our elections why
shouldn't residents of Mississippi be
allowed to vote in California elections
exactly we should I mean the United
States is the United States so yeah if
I'm a Floridian
and I'm visiting New York so why can't I
vote in New York absolutely I think we
should be able to vote wherever we
happen to be yeah should we be able to
vote in Mexico well if we're
contributing to their society and living
there for years and perhaps if there's a
law that allows us to absolutely but the
American Way was established with people
voting in the 1700s that were
undocumented so we actually were created
as a nation of people that were
undocumented and voting was yeah the
nation of illegals for sure but let's
just get back to Mexico so their
Constitution says yeah
the illegal undocumented it's kind of a
hybrid of the two but their constitution
says that foreigners aren't allowed not
allowed to participate in any way in
their politics isn't that racist well I
mean but America is not racist that's
what makes America so beautiful America
is a melting pot so that would only make
sense that we would allow people who are
contributing to our society right to
vote so that would make sense okay so
why why are we upset about Russian
influence in our elections then isn't
that kind of what we want I mean there
are a lot of Russians living here
Russian diplomats living here
why term living near kids lyac the
people contributing and then going to
the polls and hearing no no no wait hold
on why should we I'm confused why should
we be worried about foreigners
influencing our election on the one hand
if you're calling for foreigners to
influence our election on these aren't
foreigners these are people who are
living here working here their children
are in our schools they're going to our
hospitals in places where now Trump has
ice visiting to pick up people who are
undocumented kids I'm trying to track
this because I want to take it seriously
and I do you think this is the next
frontier in liberalism I think the
Democratic platform will reflect what
you're saying probably very soon tear in
America you mean the future there's no
dinner yeah that's absolutely future but
but so ambassador his lyac the russian
ambassador spent i think like 20 years
here I think his kids grew up here
certainly a big contributor economically
to the city of Washington why should I
be upset when he votes or influences our
politics well by the standards there are
so many people that we are sad that vote
right but I mean unfortunately we don't
have people voting that should be voting
we only have I think fifty-nine percent
turnout voting right now so people who
do contribute and are great people and
contributing should be allowed to vote
so okay so that would include I'm glad
we can give up on the Russian collision
narrative it was done from the beginning
and now I feel good about it because you
know what they're just transitory
Americans undocumented Americans yeah
yeah great to see you Cathy thank you
yep